[Music]
rapper xxx Tennessee Yan shot and killed
in South Florida TMZ reports the 20 year
old rapper was leaving a motorcycle
dealership in South Florida on Monday
afternoon when a gunman reportedly ran
up to his vehicle and opened fire
the Broward County Sheriff tweeted they
had responded to an incident regarding a
shooting in Deerfield Beach at 3:57 p.m.
local time and an adult male victim was
transported to an area hospital less
than an hour later the victim was
pronounced dead
xxx Tennessee on began rapping at the
age of 15 and broke onto the scene with
his 2017 single look at me and his album
question mark reached number one on the
Billboard charts despite success and a
devoted fanbase the 20 year old was
plagued by legal issues and was facing
more than a dozen felony charges and
allegations of domestic violence the
music community has begun reacting to
the news on social media Kanye tweeted
rest in peace I never told you how much
you inspired me when you were here
thank you for existing
you
[Music]